i querida royal water is a mixture of
two acids hydrochloric acid and nitric
acid the reason it's called royal water
is because it dissolves gold gold had
fascinated people for thousands of years
because doesn't dissolve in anything
doesn't tarnish always looks nice and
shiny and this was a material that could
dissolve it so it was really something
the Lion of the acids like the lion of
an animal is king of the animals so
aquilegia is a mixture of hydrochloric
acid and nitric acid but each of those
is a mixture of something in water a
solution of something water so
hydrochloric acid is hydrogen chloride
which is an atom of chlorine embodied to
an atom of hydrogen now the importance
of this is that when the HCL dissolves
in water the bond between them breaks
when you get chloride ions CL minus and
h plus hydrogen ions and it is the
formation of hydrogen ions that make
something an acid so when you have the
mixture of all these ions you get quite
a soup now the exciting thing about aqua
region is that neither of the two acids
by themselves can dissolve gold nitric
acid doesn't really react with gold very
much at all an HCl hydrochloric acid
can't get ahold of the gold gets the
reaction going but if you can get gold
into solution then it can react so what
happens is as follows the nitric acid
can attack the gold and a very small
proportion of the gold relatively few
atoms persuade didn't go into solution
and there's an equilibrium so I'm coming
off an equal number are going back on to
the
cell-surface so if you just have the
gold in there it appears to be
unaffected if you were on an atomic
scale you would see atoms coming off and
others going back but nothing changes
but when you have the hydrogen chloride
there the chloride ions can attack the
gold and turn them into a different
compound so they can't go back so more
and more and more gold atoms come off
until eventually all of it is converted
to another acid which is an acid of gold
with four chlorine atoms around it
this material is then quite soluble in
water so provided you don't have too
much gold it will all dissolve and once
you have a solution you will get a brown
a solution or greenish solution
depending how much gold is in there I've
never seen aqua regia
because it's quite a nasty material you
have to use it in a fume cupboard
because otherwise because of these fumes
of no.2 and unless you want to dissolve
gold you don't usually need this it is a
pretty good cleaning material if you
have glassware beakers things like that
that you can't clean on any other way
the sort of last resort is we'll try a
query to see if that'll do it you know
really bang the dirt and it sometimes
works not always depends what the
dirties aqua regia is Latin for aqua is
the Latin for water as in aqueducts and
also we use it in English in the words
aqueous and things like that there's all
and Rieger is the Latin for oil as in
regal and comes from the word Rex which
means a king in Latin well there's quite
a famous story about aqua regia and the
institute of niels bohr the nobel prize
winner who had an institute in
copenhagen
and at the beginning of the Second World
War when Denmark was still neutral -
German Nobel Prize winners Max von Laue
ER and Frank who had won the Nobel Prize
before the Second World will sent their
gold medals for safekeeping to Denmark
and someone in the lab at in Denmark
dissolved them in aqua regia and just
put the bottle on the shelf where there
were lots of other bottles of chemicals
and they stayed there the whole wall
because nobody realized that they were
gold and after the war the gold was
recovered the medals were restruck and
given back to the Nobel Prize winners